[Music]
hello welcome to another episode of fat
man Beyond or even maybe black man young
I guess whatever we're gonna call these
things I am here by myself because if
you have been following anything to do
with Kevin then you know he is deep in
the in the heart of New Orleans making
James Hannah Bob reboot and so it's
gonna be a minute and a half and more
than that I suppose until he's back in
the world and ready to do in there fat
man so I figured you know why the hell
not
I we wrapped the room early today so
let's talk let's ask some questions
let's uh let us get into it I am in my
office on carnival row which I haven't
been able to talk about when we recorded
the home show but I guess now I can
mention it is a big anis urban fantasy
show that will be on Amazon starring
Orlando Bloom and Cara Delevingne
it's let's see City Amazon right I don't
know when it's gonna premiere yet or
well naturally I dunno I don't know when
I can tell you it's very premiere but
the first season is already done and the
can and I'm working on the second season
so I'm so yeah it's been busy if you
want to see where fancy TV writers
office looks like here it is windows
windows windows nothing on the walls
couch coat another window lamp and me
again yeah I haven't brought anything
from home I haven't put any anything up
on the walls yet who the hell knows if
ever I will but uh but yeah so that is
that is where I am we wrap the room
early today so I have a little bit of
time to talk to you fine folks so yeah
man let's see let's see what kind of
questions we have to
and let's scroll a little bit let's see
talk about the experience in a new
writers room we are three weeks in and
most of those three weeks are usually
spent kind of getting to know each other
at least the first week is definitely
just a you know who are you people
you know what how will we gel as a unit
how will we get on with each other you
know can we be friends or at the very
least friendly will we be friends
forever and ever you know I've never
been on a show that's gone for more than
one season while I was involved in it so
so far it always feels a bit like summer
camp you know you show up you work for
20-25 weeks and you see these people
every day and then the show wraps and
you never see them again
unless just in passing like there's an
event do you in the world or you know
mutual friends and you have a dinner but
so now we're we're only kind of sniffing
each others butts
Fay's but we've also pretty much broken
a whole season of TV at least the bigger
strokes so far and now we start diving
in into the into the nitty-gritty and
it's been it's been really really great
your Congo season too so yeah let's see
in the can yes that is gross Viceroy
Craig why is toxic friend and becomes
such a thing social media has been
around over 10 years now what the [ __ ]
happened lately in the past two or three
years
all right Viceroy Craig I guess we're
gonna start with a big question and not
just like how was your day man I
honestly don't know I think that maybe
it's because even though social medias
been around for a very long time the
actual media that people have been
seeing has been pretty much what it
always has been the thing that has
changed and and you know you asked me I
would say to change for the better is
then the kinds of people who get to tell
the stories that that get the same kind
of release that movies have been getting
for 100 years previous or at the very
least 40 years previous until after Jaws
post jaws post Star Wars the kind of
movies that everybody got to see were
made by this
kind of person and that person was
almost always a guy he was almost always
a little older probably had a beard in a
baseball cap and he was almost always a
white fella and in the last five years
or so I know you by the way those movies
were almost always about people who
looked just like that director and a
decent chunk of the audience also looked
just like that director so people were
getting stories made for them made about
them made by them and they were happy
and you know fair like it's it's the
kind of thing that you want and you're
getting soup to nuts but in the last
five years or so
people have been giving more people
chances to tell stories about them or at
the very least including people who do
not check the white / dude / male /
bearded / baseball cap boxes and our
telling stories about women or telling
stories about people of color or telling
stories about the LGBTQ community and
and those people who have been getting
everything that they wanted are suddenly
being confronted with looking at faces
on screens that don't look exactly like
them and I guess some people are chafing
at that even though they're also still
getting those same other kinds of movies
that they were getting before but now
there's a person of color in their Star
Wars or there is a woman in their Marvel
or there is a whatever whatever the
thing is the thing is they want to be
upset about and so the reaction to that
has been toxic aided by the anonymity of
the internet aided by the illusion that
every thought a person has is the
thought that's worth sharing I think all
of those ingredients thrown into the big
shiny cauldron of immediate access to
people they never really had immediate
access to before and a platform that can
broadcast those thoughts immediately
has kind of led us to where we are now I
don't know if there's a way to come back
from that I'd like to hope there is
that's faster than kind of generational
drift and I guess those people will
eventually die and hopefully you know
the next generation always seems to be a
little bit more amenable to change than
the previous generation so hopefully
hopefully it you know it'll move the
needle a little bit but I think that's
how we got where we are my dime-store
sociology all right let's see em Edgar
t610 what do I think about coming to an
end I think every story needs to come to
an end at least every serialized story
there there is no story unless you have
an ending
and do you know ten seasons I guess ten
seasons is as good or run as you get for
a character like that and and yeah I
mean good for them
and find a way to plant that story find
find the the blind arrow shot of Robin
Hood to designate where he should be
buried yeah I mean I wish them nothing
but the best and yeah it's been a hell
of a run they should be super proud
let's see Steve and nerdy exploits did I
enjoy the letter Shazam trailer he
thinks it had some promising down I said
iconic moments thoughts I did enjoy I
mean it's funny it's funny I think
there's I think there is a world in
which you should be able to take a child
to a movie about a superhero wearing a
cape and have it be a somewhat light
somewhat frothy somewhat vibrant
exploration of what it means to be a
hero without the weight of the world
crashing down on it it looks fun and I
mean it's a superhero movie they should
be fun so yeah man I'm uh I'm on board
I'm always cautiously optimistic but and
at the jump when they first told me they
were making the Shazam movie with Jack
Levi who
quite a bit from Chuck I just didn't
know what to make of it but once I
started to see trailers and so they
toned they were going for us again no
and I'm down for this rhyme and what's
the best way to crank out a solid script
any tips that is too broad of a question
one you probably have to crank out five
or six not solid scripts to get to the
one that's pretty good it's it's hard
and it's difficult and the first couple
tries are going to be shitty and
everybody's first rise out of the gate
of shitty but you need to power through
the shitty to get to the good stuff so
yeah iteration and practice it's it's a
craft and the more you do it the better
you get at it
let's see nerd you entertainment did you
guys make any plans for New Orleans yet
I know you guys are going to come to the
New York New Jersey area anytime soon it
does not look like we're gonna do a live
show in New Orleans I think Kevin is a
little busy directing and starring in a
feature film that leaves a lot of
bandwidth to actually put together a
live show so sadly it bums me out a
little bit only cuz I left New Orleans
and I love doing the podcast so to get
those two things together at once oh
it's like dreamy and I don't know about
New York New Jersey we every every year
we talk about doing it and every year it
doesn't seem to come together but
fingers crossed we'll get there one of
these days
it's a rich Channing what are my
thoughts on the upcoming Godzilla movie
I my thought to the upcoming Godzilla
movie are much like my thoughts but they
sound a lot like pink in the brain which
is if you're going to give me another
Godzilla movie I will go see another
Godzilla movie
it is a formative part of my youth so I
am I'm down like a pound to see another
one of those bad boys let's see
definitely not Dillon predictions for
Game of Thrones final season it'll be
six episodes long each one 90 minutes
somebody will sit on the throne and lots
of people will die beyond that
I don't really have any predictions I
never read the books because I forgot
how to read but also they made a TV show
so I didn't have to read the books so I
don't have the same detailed level of
granular dissection of those stories and
what I'm expecting and what I've been
wanting for years and years and years I
hope they do not give us what we want
when that show is good it doesn't give
you what you want it gives you what you
need and then I hope that that Benioff
and Weiss figure out what it is we need
for this thing when it comes to its
close our loss of say that HBO is
leaving money on the table by not
putting those in theaters because I
would absolutely spend $15 every week to
go see those episodes on the big screen
and I do not think I'm alone in that and
like hey I also pay for HBO and I would
be fine to do both so that's just me
that's just me
let's see Jay hunt 2013 how would I
write up Ben Affleck in the current DC
movie universe I would treat Batman like
you treat James Bond and never explain
why there's a new James Bond there just
is Batman is the reason why we're
showing up not whoever's wearing the
Cape
let's see comic book number 27 any
advice for a comic book geek about to
get married in two months depends on
what you want advice on what to do with
your comic books can't tell you that I'm
hoping you've had conversations with
your fiance about what you're going to
do with all of your [ __ ] you know that's
that that's an important conversation to
have but let's see comic book lover if
you were a gentleman realize that you
were going to lose almost every argument
if you're a lady realize you're going to
win every argument but be a little
magnanimous about it
compromise is the key to long-term
relationship health you must give and
she must give and through that giving
you a both find a place in each other's
hearts
that is about all I got and don't go to
sleep angry
let's see print PC principal own darks
forgive me for backing up I'm getting
old in my eyes you're not great how long
can the MCU being the limelight the MCU
I feel like it will at some point and
flow and rise and diminish what Cap'n's
post endgame I think will tell that
story a little bit because we will
interface is not very far from now when
you do not have Robert Downey jr.
without a man you do not have Chris
Evans's and Steve Rogers you do not have
Chris Hemsworth as Thor and what how do
they extend that universe the
introduction and inclusion of the x-men
and Fantastic Four probably a big part
of that but but yeah it's a what happens
when you put those particular toys to
bed what are the toys are we going to
get let's see ck howling do I like pizza
duh I'm bbz ducky thanks waving at us a
Stan Lee event you've got it
bear customs I need a writing job please
help me please I cannot help you I do
not have jobs to give 10 11 20 hey what
did I miss
oh so much so much we went so deep man
we solved everything I'm sorry you
missed it you just have to wait for
later
let's see information silos thanks Kyle
let's see CLE Dave cleverly Dave 33 wood
I cast as dream and death if there were
a Sandman series or move oh it's a movie
I feel like there there's a world in
which I would like to time travel then
go get young Bjork to be death
um because there's there's there's some
Daffy Wonder alienness to her that is
kind of irresistible I saw a video today
it's on the youtubes somewhere of Bjork
explaining how a television works
it feels oldish maybe a couple years old
but it is so like elfin magic Daffy
wonderful that I kind of wanted to see
it like mr. Rogers starring Bjork which
it just explains random technology [ __ ]
bye bye bye taking the cover off and
explaining to herself what it looks like
looks like a small city and efficient
elevator taking the pictures from the
bottom of the city to the screen but
yeah she would have been great and
there's there's a part of me that that
completely sees the Benedict Cumberbatch
as as dream
he's got the cheekbones for it I can
also see Killian Murphy as as dream as
Morpheus I mean the super nerdy me would
really like to see Laurence Fishburne as
Morpheus squared but I'm afraid that
dream is never gonna happen
let's definitely not Dylan again have I
seen the trailer for the new James Bond
film bright burn I have seen that new
trailer and it actually looks pretty
interesting it's it's a little bit
Chronicle it's a little bit Superman I
mean it's a lot Superman you know it's
it's it's very interesting I feel a
little bit bad that it's being marketed
as a James Bond film because he didn't
direct it but but no I'm curious I'm
always curious about sort of alternate
takes on well-established kind of pop
mythology yes
fellas machine any plans to revisit the
road on you and Kev can kill on a team
match I quite enjoyed my time at this
row down the couple of matches that I
did unfortunately Schmo down does not
merge very well
being gainfully employed you know it's
rather during the week when I have a job
or it's during the weekend when I'm you
know one I spent time with my family
excuse me so so I don't think there are
any plans to go back in the future and
also like there's there's the point at
which that game is funny because it's
hey let's just talk about like movie and
trivia [ __ ] and here's the the weird
tonnage of stuff that I have in my brain
that I can't explain and then there's
the I gotta study and I'm not looking to
study so I think I think my time and the
shimmer down is over but I could also be
super super wrong
let's see Advent crash what is my
favorite spy movie I am I am quite fond
of Goldfinger I it is the rock III James
Bond movies and then it's the one with a
formula that gets gets kind of imprinted
the best I really like just you know
right now I think of all of the of all
the dang the Craig's I mean that's my
sister the strongest one trying to think
if there's any other room spy stuff it's
kind of like outside of the James Bond I
mean I'm I'm a fan of project a only
because I want to see Jackie Chan do
awesome Jackie Chan [ __ ] no but yeah
there you go
let's see Kelvin Kelvin Keller Brad 2501
wants to know my storage for Black
Panther to my story for Black Panther to
is ready and waiting for Disney to pay
me to give it to them beyond that glass
it is mine um let's see bum bum bum
let's see k dinero six what would have
been your dream production to work on
pasture president I would have loved to
have been in the Battlestar Galactica
writers room if you if you can't tell
the depth of my love for Battlestar
Galactica
you should just go and listen to my
other podcast the Battlestar Galactica
that I co-host with Tricia Helfer in
which we talk about nothing but
Battlestar Galactica
and yeah I have I have such a mad
respect for that show for coming out of
the gates are strong Buffy the Vampire
Slayer would have been awesome I feel
like The West Wing would have been an
interesting place to be even though I'd
never would have gotten to write a
script because I work and wrote
everything I see Buffy
I love Firefly to death it would have
been a great year although I'm not sure
that that level of heartbreak would have
been easily overcome about to be able to
do really good work for one year in
Fernie and network not to get it and for
the public to not love it quite enough
until much later I would have liked to
have been on one more show one more show
you know what parks and recreation I
feel like I mean I've heard that sitcom
rooms can be merciless and awful and
horrible kind of pits of despair and
self-loathing but something tells me
that the parks and recreation room was a
little bit more bright than that and I
love that short of death so yeah that
those those would have been my Jamie
dreams see Kyle and reading how I talk
about how I picked my writing projects
obviously part of it is paying the bill
but what makes you want to take a job
this has been the first year coming off
of Castle Rock II coming along from
Treadstone that I've actually had a
level of choice previously it had been
somebody wants to pay me to do this work
I will go do this work because I've
always wanted to write TV and to get the
chance to write TV is is a dream beyond
dreams and so if somebody wants to let
me do that I was always going to jump at
it but after those two shows and started
looking around for what the next thing
would be the reps did bring some stuff
down the pike that I just didn't like
and for me if it's not something that I
create myself it was not something that
I believed in it came from from my heart
that I've been dying to sort of be dying
to tell the thing that makes me
interested in another show or it makes
me turn away from taking an opportunity
is because there's something about the
show that means that that is such that I
couldn't give my full throated support
to it that I would be sitting in the
room trying to think of ideas for a show
that I fundamentally didn't believe in
you know and then and then the reasons
why I don't believe in it or rarely
because of story reasons because a lot
of those can be fixed but they're almost
always philosophy reasons you know a
show that that that has a weird bent of
misogyny or excessive violence or just
as its head in the wrong place that that
I couldn't I couldn't give full throated
creativity or support to sends me away
the things that I respond to in shows
are our worlds that I think are fun to
play in worlds that offer story
opportunities and character
opportunities characters that are that
are rich and layered and complex and
conflicted and all of that awesome and
then a storyteller who has a vision for
what that show is knows where he feels
or she feels like it's her end knows
where she thinks the the great joys and
the nooks and crannies and can
communicate that vision effectively I'm
happy to strap in and ride to be into
the road with that person on that show
let's see
how did I feel about Spike Lee winning
Best Director I would have felt much
better if you won Best Director sadly he
won Best Adapted Screenplay I think I
think that that award was ironically
some of the problems with Black Panther
were on the screenplay where the
liberties they took with the facts in
order to create
a thriller because the true story did
not involve a bombing at the end but it
felt very much like the Academy which
does this all the time is there's a
person who has an unassailably important
career who we had not given a real Oscar
to before and so here's our chance to
reward them for a lifetime of cinema
it's the you know Paul Newman Ford for
color of money
it's the optional for Scent of a Woman
you know it's like both of those guys
have done far far better work far
earlier but the Oscar is just in the
Academy didn't recognize him for it so
here's the trophy we should have given
you years ago here's the trophy spike
should have gotten if we do the right
thing and didn't get you know that said
happy to see that guy win because again
like do the right thing Malcolm X two of
the best movies ever made that clearly
should have won some kind of trophies
from the Oscars I never did so I'm glad
he won I wish it was for Best Director
though I can't slide Roma idea anyway
let's see if Jordan peels new movie
which is called us doesn't do well
critically or financially what does that
mean for his career for the future
nobo feel like 519 something tells me
that had this been 10 years ago and and
Jordan you got the chance to make a
movie at this level and it failed it
would it would it would be irreparably
harm into his career or at the very
least it would take him 10 years to get
out of movie Jail to make another one I
feel right now he has so much momentum
behind him a US will do well because
there's enough of a fanbase out there
who came from get out will show up the
movie was if I had to guess was also
done cheap enough that it doesn't have
to be a 500 million dollar blockbuster
to to get into the black if he spent 40
million dollars on it it makes 80
everybody wins
I think he keeps on rolling I think he
has enough irons and enough fires and
enough goodwill from a community from
the community from the movie-going
public behind them that it's even if it
doesn't do well it's a it's a bump in
the road and not a wall so yeah I think
he's all good
let's see what Charlotte's buddy redoing
excellent with Channing my thoughts in
the Oscars I already wrote about them
for The Hollywood Reporter so don't know
if I need to dig back into that
particular well mish-mosh 66 what do I
think about it just over replacing Will
Smith in Suicide Squad - I mean I'm all
for a Giselle but in most things I think
it's an it's an easy swap out and
probably better for the movie Will
Smith's Will Smith's magnitude always
imbalance that movie because Deadshot
needed some semblance of a story he
needed some reason to be doing the
things he was doing he needed you know a
daughter that he was sacrificing for it
did the movie and some it in some
configuration needed to be about him I
think gage Rossella
doesn't quite bring that level of weight
to it and not but he's like not weighs
the wrong word
he doesn't bring that level of
gravitational pull to it and that the
movie suddenly has to be about him again
I am still wanting for him to get more
of his own spotlight I feel like he's
you know he's in the Hobson and Shaw
movie as the bad guy he's he was in
Pacific Rim as the the elder statesman
he's in this is part of an ensemble like
I'm still waiting for the big shiny
honking dangerous Alba kicks ass
for himself in his own thing that is not
called the Dark Tower um so yes I feel
good action bentonite I got that played
through Red Dead Redemption - yeah no I
finished it no month ago a month and a
half ago or so and I loved it
it started slower than I would have
liked it's almost as if the game was
daring you to engage with it but once
you once you got out of the snow even
once you start to get into into the
world like Arthur Morgan reveal himself
to be as as great a protagonist as as I
could imagine I could hope for
so ya know I loved it and tragic this
rock at the end and especially because
you know where it's going it's the best
way of doing a prequel which is sort of
filling in some of the blanks and
finding new story but also letting the
tragedy of what will later come um
hangover what that first game is yeah I
was awesome the N ba ba ba-ba which non
comic-book movie was my favorite movie
from last year and the fog I can try to
remember what was on my top 10 list it
escapes me at the moment but I will say
this most surprising movie was the night
comes for us what you're gonna find that
flicks which is maybe the greatest
action movie I've seen in about five
years definitely since John wick it is
my favorite thing since John wick so yes
Advent crash again I finished the draft
of my screenplay how do I suggest you
make changes if you don't have a lot of
people to give notes well if you do have
any people to give them notes give them
a draft and have them read it I would
not add the Cape I wouldn't advocate
like any of the kind of screenwriting
gurus will charge you money to read and
give you feedback and promise to
interview in a competition and like
that's there is there is so little
from that because I mean the the math of
it is is that they're trying to make
money off of your work
and by telling you that you're not good
enough and telling them if they can help
make you better is how they're going to
do that and that I don't think will get
you where you want to be I'll find that
the people that you love even if it's a
family over it's a close friend who
doesn't have experience in it see what
they think and just like take it apart
you know read it reread it make sure it
works make sure it flows if there's
movies that you like in the same vein to
watch those movies and see how those
beats play out and not to copy them at
all but just to see you know here's how
the emotional math pays out here's how
the plot math pays out but yeah and just
make sure that your character stuff is
strong because at the end of the day
that's why people show up for the movies
I guess there's a spectacle years
there's the the the explosions and the
car chase and the laser beams the robots
which are all cool but we go we we go
into a dark Theater because we want to
be entertained and we want to form some
kind of bond with the characters who are
entertaining this so concentrating on
that stuff Sjogren's Alex do I think the
Harry Potter TV show would work
abso-fucking-lutely you know I don't
think I don't think you would call it a
Harry Potter TV show but I think you
know and I don't necessarily want the
prequel I'm not a big fan of the
fantastic beast movies but there's 20
different magical academies around the
world each one of those schools has
somebody in it who is it was remarkable
so take me to some of those other
schools tell me what those kids are
about tell me you know play out a
different sort of global magical threat
of which Hogwarts plays a small part you
know what happens when the Dementors go
to every other school you know looking
for other kids with power I think I
think there's it is a big canvas that
you can absolutely that you can
absolutely play with would read rub and
seem more realistic than to you than
traditional Robin I mean I love the
cheeseburgers
um say Lord newbie will I be in the
German Bob Kahn scene I vote for a
Silent Bob crossover costume
I don't know I could not tell you
let's see miles left what got me into
writing what got me into writing is that
I couldn't draw like I love telling
stories I love comic books I tried to
draw and could not do it and and so I
started writing Denton's and Dragons
also played a part in it you know dozens
and dragons which I haven't played them
in 20 years but it was my first exposure
to collaborative storytelling like
you're all telling a story together and
that was a ton of fun I wanted to be a
director when I went to college and made
a couple of short films that were
goodish and and the good was the fact
that nobody cares about your student
film as much as you do and so everybody
else are you relying on to help you make
it is going to give you 60% then 100%
cuz you're not paying them they're doing
it out the kindness of their hearts and
November trained to do it and so I
realized that those short films were
never quite what I had in my head but
the only way to get what I had in my
head out was to write and on the page it
could be exactly as I wanted to be there
was nobody between me and the
effectiveness of a story being told so I
started to write and that's that's sort
of holid but that's how I began to enter
the world was as a person who works with
words let's see Gilboa licious tour has
a white whale of a script one that
you've worked on for years but can never
quite complete um I sort of feel like if
there was a script that you started and
haven't been able to finish you were
never meant to finish it and there are a
couple of things that I have that are
better that are you know collaborations
with other people that just petered out
at some point you know I don't have
anything that I started writing myself
that I've never finished once I got it
to script
there are ideas that are kind of
half-baked that are sitting on a hard
drive
there are outlines that have never quite
been coalesced into a thing and I find
that if I don't have the passion usually
when I start writing I start writing an
outline there so just writing into a
Word document like here's here's kind of
the loose ideas that I have and maybe
some characters and maybe the world a
bit and maybe who the lights back on
maybe just just whatever and kind of
wool gathering my brain will do and then
the more I start to work on it the more
it begins to take a shape and then I
start building it into answer and if
it's TV it's five acts if it's movie
it's three acts and then start saying
right here's here's the second plot
point here's the big thing here here's
the reversal here's the hero's lowest
points just start doing all that work
and then I start refining and refining
it and and I find that if I can actually
write the entire outline without being
so excited to actually start writing it
I'm probably not gonna write it because
there's stuff that I've written that
I've loved the most I gave up on the
outline halfway through because I said
why dick around with the outline when I
can be writing the [ __ ] script the
things that don't get finished I clearly
didn't love enough and you have to love
it to live with it first long as you
have to live with it
so yeah so there you go Merrill bar a
marrow thought something that's like
Spielberg stuff I think you know Steven
Spielberg is hands-down top ten pantheon
of film directors ever you know he was I
think Hitchcock maybe referred to him
was it Orson Welles I haven't Orson
Welles no it was maybe Orson Welles
talking about Spielberg that he was the
first one of us who didn't see the
proscenium meaning that he was the first
director who really didn't come with any
attachment to the theater to the stage
to the classic way of putting drama up
on its feet he's he's you know he's
[ __ ] Spielberg that said it feels
like this is the weirdest [ __ ] hill
for him to die on
and because you know movies or movies
and we know what movies are we know when
we encounter movies and we know when we
encounter TV TV is serialized there's
more than one chapter you know and and
it's not that it's a sequel is that we
are telling this particular chunk of
story in parts and that's television
there are already our rules on the bull
on the table to say here's what a movie
is here's what a what a TV show is well
here's what's anonymity here's what's
eligible for the Academy Awards and
here's what's not you have to to run the
theater in New York or LA for a week and
you have to have a review in the New
York Times or the yellow times and if
you can do either of those things you
can qualify to be a movie those are
there if Netflix does those things and
their movies it's no different than you
know a regular movie studio making a
movie putting it in theaters and then
putting it on cable afterwards it going
straight to DVD like those real still
movies and it's also somewhat
hypocritical because most of the Academy
watches movies on screeners anyways
you're watching them at home and not in
the theater and and the point that
Netflix is opening the doors to
production for people who ordinarily
wouldn't be able to walk through them
you know people of color people from
disadvantaged backgrounds people from
from all over the world who don't get B
access to the to the studio system that
Spielberg has had since he was 22 years
old it's just that it feels it feels
like a weird generational thing for him
to be for the for the boy genius to
suddenly be the old man crusty genius is
not a good look and I can't quite see
his I don't I don't see his side of the
story I don't see what what makes that
version of it better so yeah that is
that is just me I just think he's wrong
let's say Tony Targaryen I'm excited for
the James grants was that's what ya like
I like that dude's work I like his
Sensibility
and it seems as if what that movie needs
is fun it needs to be it needs
be like whip-smart it needs to be fast
and he's to be lean it needs to be fun
so yeah let's say Hugh he wanders and
Ponder's any plans to do another show in
Canada I don't know there's no plans but
I would never I would never turn it down
I will be at the northern fan con in
Prince George again in May keV is at
least at this point not slated to join
me but maybe I'll do a solo thing I
don't know what happens but the amount
of time keV spends in Vancouver it would
surprise me if we don't do another one
up there la de-da-de-dum
[Music]
the jack nook Kenneth Thundercats movie
work I mean you could just [ __ ] go
into avatar and color shift everything
to orange I think it could totally work
yeah I mean I'd watch that might not be
a black hole I know though yeah what the
[ __ ] not yeah I think you could do that
way too raw have I seen an umbrella
Academy I have not yet I know I'm an
awful nerd I'm sorry I want to I want
desperately to but it's being being in
in the room has has swallowed much of my
bandwidth so when I get home it's uh
it's like I just want to watch stuff
that night not to say that I don't have
to engage in but it's I know that once I
start watching a Braille Academy it's
gonna be like four o'clock in the
morning we've of me just stop watching
Umbrella Academy and I can't be doing
that yet so uh so yeah not yet but I
want to load ro Bo saw an ad for Neil
Gaiman's master class as an entry-level
rider do you think it's worth taking I I
cannot speak with any authority as to
whether or not the master classes are
worth her or not I've never watched one
I've never listened to one I've heard
people rave about the the sorting one
I've heard the Neil Gaiman one is pretty
good I think that especially when you're
beginning and especially from somebody
like Neil
you can totally learn you learning at
the feet of a master is always a good
thing if you can and if this if this
opens those doors for that
I don't know how expensive they are but
give it a go I mean it can't hurt I used
to read a bunch of screenwriting books
when I was first starting out I would I
would read like a book a week and after
a while they all began to kind of tell
you the same thing because what they
can't teach you is how to tell your
story they can teach you how to tell
their stories they can give me some of
the tools to tell stories but they can't
tell you how to tell a story and so
after a while it just used to be if I
can pull one interesting thing out of
these two hundred pages it was worth it
and then after a while I stopped being
able to find those interesting things
when you at the beginning you erode go
for it see if there's an interesting
thing in there and give it a shot okay
let's see advice for my Craig again how
do you write for other genders races etc
when you're not part of that group is it
as simple as just getting input and
advice from those groups you're trying
to represent in your work it requires a
the knowledge that you don't know I'm
sure that is some confucius thing like
the first step in wisdom is knowing that
you're not wise but it's knowing what
you don't know and then be research so I
as a black person I kind of understand
the black experience in as much as I
understand my black experience which is
not every black experience I I know a
lot of different kind of black people I
know a lot of different kind of people
in different places well I haven't lived
their lives I lived my life
and I feel like there's a level of
authenticity I can bring to it because
it's a lived-in experience I have been
for my entire life
confronted with media about people who
are not me
so almost every TV show I watch almost
every book I read almost every comic
book I read almost ever
movie I see almost everything anywhere
is oriented not to me but to a wide
audience so I've had nothing but
exposure to those lives to that mindset
so I do feel with some confidence that I
can write those characters as well women
I have never been will never be do not
get to see merely enough media about
though that's changing but I have found
ways to surround myself with women just
because they have find women super
interesting because they don't think
like men and men don't think that much
so but but it's still it's presuming
that I can suddenly write a woman which
is just like writing a man I didn't
character there was things but not quite
it's realizing that that women are going
through life like they've got one hand
tied behind their backs as far as pay
equity and opportunities and you know
even without getting into the awfulness
of sexual harassment in me too and
uncomfortable workplace environments and
unsafe work environments and all that
[ __ ] it's just the world is not arrayed
to benefit them in the way that it's
built to benefit men but it's it's
realizing that I don't know that and
then doing that research so pick up
books watch documentaries go out into
the world talk to people and realize
that yes every character is a human
person and every human person has once
and needs and the drum of a story is
finding out what a person wants and
keeping them from having it until the
very last minute it's the the obstacles
in the way of getting what you want and
that part of it is true for anybody but
the way in which a person will go about
getting what they want and the way in
which they will deal with the obstacles
you put in front of them differs
depending on their their life experience
so do the work like that's the the
problem I think that comes is when
people don't do that work when writers
don't
is that they have to try and find a way
to put themselves in somebody else's
shoes and that only comes through
research so yeah do do the work
let's see blah blah blah who would would
you show up to a modern-day Keaton
Batman movie because of Keaton if it's
Batman Beyond he's super Bruce Wayne
hell yeah let's see just Reggie official
will I sign autographs on WonderCon I am
NOT currently slated to sign autographs
anywhere and I have a booth I don't have
a I don't I don't I don't have any time
to set up other publishers to do it I
might look into it maybe a Top Cow but
if you spot me walking around on
Saturday and then there's anything I can
do by all means
flag me I will sign whatever you got
Reggie let's see sure sure hell yeah
that would be awesome
let's see wonders and Ponder's again are
you optimistic about the next
Ghostbusters movie I think I talked
about this on the last home show
we're keV said that he'd sat down with
Jason Reitman and got the inside scoop I
mean I try to be cautiously optimistic
about most things but I also like I said
we have one amazing Ghostbusters movie
sometimes you just catch lightning in a
bottle and sometimes you just need to
reckon with the fact that you're not
gonna catch it again and I don't think
whatever Ghostbusters mummy again now
will live up to what we expect it to be
I feel like we're to a certain degree
asking ourselves to be disappointed so I
guess maybe that's not looking forward
to it anyway let's see young Bjork
interacting Lord lubing hey thank you
for congratulating me that was super fun
[Music]
let's see remand any hope for John cast
aspersion Iranian John's five I think
Rico would be cool I I am kind of in my
heart of hearts praying that we don't
get an Indiana Jones five again like I
just feel like it's I love Harrison Ford
I do but he's pushing 80 years old and
that's not Indiana Jones to me and I
don't know what version of that is him
passing the torch because where that was
supposed to be naina Jones for I think
it's probably about time to recast let's
see I have never been through sure I
would like to go retro geek if you guys
invite us to come to Australia to do a
show we will totally come to do a show
[Music]
about Deadpool Jack not what happened
with there were child skis I honestly
don't know I think that I remember when
John Singleton was doing press for um
for boys in the hood he said that that
was the movie he went to film school to
make and he did and he made and it's
great but I think that for some
storytellers they have a limited number
of stories they want to tell some can go
on for years and years and years some
have endless supplies or stories others
amen you know like there's sometimes
there's just the one and and if that one
is great
then fantastic so so I don't know if the
Wachowskis great story they needed to
tell was the matrix and they told it and
they've been you know taking big swings
and stuff you know for a while and the
studios to a certain degree will end up
indulge that
because they want another matrix they
were always wondering the matrix so
Cloud Atlas wasn't that speed racer'
wasn't that Jupiter ascending wasn't
that
will they get more shocks I don't know
maybe but maybe the matrix was the story
they were put on this earth to tell and
they told it so yeah I don't know I
don't know I don't know let's see
okay spiders a monic huge fan a recently
build bins Mary much of Castle Rock is
wondering to have any idea about when
the second season will be coming out in
production any favorite horror movies I
do not know much about the second season
of Castle Rock
let's off again I still have friends in
that room I don't know when production
is supposed to start but if I had to
guess it will be out sometime this year
because I think Hulu is invested in
having more Castle Rock and more Stephen
King on your tubes before the years out
my favorite horror movies Evil Dead 2
The Exorcist the first movie scare the
[ __ ] out of me
the ring the remake the thing
Carpenter's The Thing nightmare Elm
Street Zack Snyder's Dawn of the Dead
cabin in the woods yeah I love those
okay let's see I'm probably about three
minutes from having to shut down so
let's see what else we got ultimate
survivor Richard Grieco
oh my playing video games yes check that
I'm going to make you watch Battlestar
Galactica protagonist radio hey man is
doing a drag to read I picked it up to
prepare for the movie but I always heard
was pretty dry Reed
I'm trying to remember I I was so
obsessed with david lynch's doing that I
bought the knob Lonnie held it because I
couldn't understand David Lynch is doing
it I wanted to know what the [ __ ] was
going on and I found it fascinating
it is definitely it is dense it is dense
as hell he goes super deep into like the
ecology of Arrakis and the political
workings and how Emperor Shaddam the
forth ruled over Sonam the like all of
that stuff it's it's the George are
Martin of science fiction [ __ ] or george
RR martin is the Frank Herbert of
fantasy [ __ ] but I found a captivating I
really did it's it's it's a book about a
superhero I mean the especially the
first three novels the the books to
follow Paul it's the what happens when a
when a superhero when a superhuman
enters a world that's not prepared for
it
how does he throw off everything how
does he throw off the social structure
how does he throw off the political
structure what happens when him when a
person becomes a god what happens to the
world around him and then what happens
to him himself and I think that question
is super fascinating and doom for all of
its kind of deep deep thoughts about
deep deep things is they're really
interesting reading in that way all
right Joe Koch right this would be the
last question what are my Holy Grail
comics and Holy Grail see how best to
interpret that what are the books that I
love the most
[Music]
Sandman Dark Knight Returns martial law
I'm a preacher
why the last man mm-hmm the authority
trans metropolitan global frequency was
a big one ellos Han Stila and the x-men
you know like my III
I came to comics via Secret Wars and
from there I went to spider-man and I
went to the x-men Claremont's run on the
x-men and and and that's what comics
were for me for a while and I was Marvel
for a good long while and and then when
Dark Knight Returns came out and when
they kind of indie comics boom started
like I sort of brought in my horizons
but but yeah those those are my Holy
Grails I don't have a ton of wall books
I I think maybe I have a teenage meeting
two turtles number one third printing
somewhere which wasn't a wall book when
I bought it I just bought it his [ __ ]
Turtles man I feel like I had a walking
dead number one and threw it out no I
wouldn't throw it out but I lost I moved
a couple of times I think I lost him in
the shuffle
but um well yeah sadly there are boys
and girls I think we are done with this
episode of black men beyond sands Kevin
who is off making cinema dreams come
true for himself and for many others we
will be back in a non determined time
let your ways back in the world I think
he's shooting until the end of March so
hopefully back in April we'll be back in
the cantina to do this proper but yes so
for this episode of fat man Beyond I
have been mark barnard and Kevin Smith
has been Kevin Smith tuned in saying fat
time same fat channel smack ash dot-com
or youtube.com slash Kevin Smith thanks
guys I'll see you soon
you
you